just in time
want me to introduce my mother-in-law
Clara my wife Michele and my daughter
Silvia in time stars Justin Timberlake
and Amanda Seyfried and Olivia Wilde as
well started by Andrew Niccol it will
also directed a similar similar
science-fiction film called Gattaca
plots aren't similar but the style is
this film starts in a dystopian future
world in which everyone has a time clock
on their wrists now this clock counts
down the currency is now time you can
buy time anything that you do purchase
you purchase with time there's no more
money you want to buy a cup of coffee it
might cost you four minutes the next day
it could cost you six minutes it's like
gas nowadays whoa where's the rest never
met the quota my units are up from last
week so is quota
it tells a story of a man played by
Justin Timberlake who decides to fight
against the system that he thinks is
just ruining the world and he thinks
it's not working and then it needs to go
away he meets up with Amanda Seyfried
who's the daughter of probably the
richest man in the world in other words
he has a lot of time on his hands and
who's on his tail none other than the
great
Killian Murphy yes one of my favorite
actors wanted to say his best actors in
my opinion how old are you 28 105 the
day comes when you've had enough if you
had as much time as I have what would
you do with it sure as hell wouldn't
waste it I really enjoyed this film and
I'll tell you why I kind of thought it
was like a different version of the
fugitive of Harrison Ford it's a very
similar story where Killian Murphy is
kinda in the Tommy Lee Jones role where
he's after Justin Timberlake but Justin
Timberlake is doing some of the things
that they're after him for things he's
doing are against the system but that's
because the system is corrupt and the
system isn't working so he's stealing
time and giving it to people and stuff
and you know to them that's breaking the
law but to us we can see that that is
the only way that certain things are
gonna balance out in this movie his name
is will Salas you can't hide a hundred
years in the ghetto you know that time
will get you killed
hey mom I'm gonna get out of here I just
wouldn't know what to do if I lost a
movie has a really really good look the
whole time I was thinking man the
director photography must be really good
and sure enough he's my favorite
director photography Roger Deakins I
love the way all his films look he gives
all his films a really nice orange glow
everything is just framed beautifully no
shakey cam the action sequences either
that's a huge plus for me no shaggy cam
that's really cool Justin Timberlake has
officially proven in my mind anyway that
he is a serious talent regards to acting
this might be the best I've seen him
manage Seyfried was oh oh man she looked
good in this movie and of course so did
Olivia Wilde I'm sorry to have to bring
up the party mr. Weiss I just need a
word with your friend
this is my damn tasting you can't do
that why they keeping me alive some of
the problems I had with the movie where
it took no time at all to explain how
they got into this world the movie opens
with one sentence that is supposed to
kind of avoid that entire question and I
would have liked to have known more
about that I would have liked to have
known more about the history of the
events that happened that led up to the
mankind being like this also the tone of
the film shifts a lot there's it starts
off with Justin Timberlake kind of
slumming in this ghetto like area then
almost Sunny's in a much more prosperous
era then he's back to the ghetto again
and back and forth and certain tonal
shifts in the film didn't really seem
natural to me it didn't really flow like
I would have liked it to I'm gonna make
them pay I'm gonna take them for
everything they've got
come on come on help yourselves take the
time and treat you put enough time
and you upset the whole system let's
hope so my grapes with the film are few
and far between though because I really
think that the acting here is good for
this material especially Killian Murphy
I really liked his performance
Timberlake was good Seyfried was good
Murphy was good I enjoyed the film was
it was nicely directed it all looks very
nice I'm gonna give the film a B+ his
crime wasn't taking time he was giving
it away if you liked my review you can
subscribe to my channel and get stuck by
now